>> Jon: HEY, WELCOME TO "THE
DAILY SHOW."
MY NAME IS JON STEWART.
OH WE HAVE A GOOD SHOW FOR YOU
TONIGHT.
WE'VE PUT IT TOGETHER.
LATER ON IN THE PROGRAM, AL
JAZEERA AMERICA CORRESPONDENT
SUE TURTON.
WE'RE GOING TO TALK ABOUT THE
THREE JOURNALISTS THAT HAVE
BEEN JAILED IN EGYPT AND, IN
FACT, IN FACT, WE'LL START
TONIGHT IN THE MIDDLE EAST,
WHERE ISRAEL --
>> WHAT?
ISRAEL ISN'T SUPPOSED TO DEFEND
ITSELF?
>> OH YEAH IF MEXICO BOMBED
TEXAS WOULD WE EXERCISE
RESTRAINT?
>> WHAT OTHER COUNTRY IS HELD TO
THE SAME STANDARD AS ISRAEL?
>> [ALL SPEAKING AT ONCE]
>> IT'S A 4,000-YEAR-OLD
CONFLICT.
>> DEMOCRACY IN THE MIDDLE
EAST --
[BLEEPED]
>> SELF-HATING JEW.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jon: THAT WAS, THAT WAS
WEIRD.
[LAUGHTER]
ANYWAY, WHAT I WAS, WHAT I WAS
SAYING WAS LAST THURSDAY SAW THE
START OF A NEW GROUND
OFFENSIVE LAUNCHED BY ISRAEL.
>> [ALL SPEAKING AT ONCE]
[BLEEPED]
>>TRADITION! TRADITION.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jon: UM, HOLY [BLEEPED].
LOOK, OBVIOUSLY THERE ARE MANY
STRONG OPINIONS ON THIS ISSUE,
BUT JUST MERELY MENTIONING
ISRAEL OR QUESTIONING IN ANY WAY
THE EFFECTIVENESS OR HUMANITY OF
ISRAEL'S POLICIES IS NOT THE
SAME THING AS BEING PRO-HAMAS.
>> SO YOU'RE AGAINST MURDERED
CHILDREN?
>> FREE GAZA, FREE GAZA!
[ALL SPEAKING AT ONCE]
>> ZIONIST PIG.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jon: YOU NOW WHAT,
[BLEEPED] IT.
WHY DON'T WE JUST TALK ABOUT
SOMETHING LIGHTER LIKE UKRAINE?
>> YEAH. I'M GOOD WITH THAT.